[Music]
we're just talking returned to comic-con
we're back baby we are back yes they
finally allowed us back in reunion tours
have been strong it has been yeah so far
so good they literally like told us not
to come back like we had a big
workaholics panel and they didn't like
us they're like now you guys are good
yeah I guess our fans were a little too
rowdy yeah they're a little rowdy San
Diego that's strong yeah these guys and
it is a comic book we have to allow them
back in we found a way we found a way
based off a comic book but going
Animated what was the idea how did it
start what was the inception yeah as a
fabulous furry freak brothers Blake
actually showed me the cartoon or the
comic itself and I was like oh this is
awesome
and it's three characters and you know
from doing workaholics we were like we
understand how to write to those
archetypes and I was like this would be
such a good cartoon and then the
producers actually came to us like right
at the same time as we were we were
reading the books yeah and it just so
happened that they were looking to
develop the property right as we were
starting to read the comics and and then
it all it all worked out and here we are
that's rad yeah fate is not usually that
kind about adapting problem yeah it was
it was like symbiotic yeah all all all
praise to the Freak brothers yeah all
them freaks out there but it is it's a
fun it's a fun cartoon man I'm really
excited for people to see it it's like
it's gonna be like edgy and raw and
r-rated and in the vein of like big
mouths yeah like you're like I can't
believe they're getting away with this
and that's that's what we're what we're
going for for this to live in this
Golden Age of animation I think yeah
yeah with spider-verse being I think
best picture of the year best animated
best picture and then move out like love
death of robots which is insane yeah and
like you mentioned big mouth there's a
lot of clout in animation right now is
that something that drew you to wanted
it to go that direction instead of
making another live-action thing with
you guys teaming up especially yeah well
I mean I think we grew up
the generation where we just worshipped
cartoons you know like we grew up with
some of the best ones and it's like yeah
Care Bears being the best one of all
time but yeah and just we've we've done
voices on other animated projects in
that and it's just it's just a lot of
fun and yeah I think it was just kind of
a another dream job that we fell into so
yeah we uh yeah we've done animated
animation on different projects but this
is the first time that were at least for
me that I'm developing from from
beginning to end
yeah and it's cool to have more of a
creative say in the process now you guys
work together for years like to just be
like well that's another day at the
office around decade well it yeah it's
it's like I think we get along so well
with each other and we're best friends
and so there's never really a time when
Blake thinks something's funny and I
don't you know yeah yeah definitely your
sensibilities start to sync up for sure
and then you get good at shorthand and
all that and like not getting feelings
hurt if the idea is bad and all that so
Blake screams that means like you're
stupid I take out a lot of aggression on
Adam but yeah now on a separate ATD note
for me dope to me is a certain amazing
movie which you also
yes dope just follows me everywhere I go
yeah yeah it is definitely the hair I
wish I could just pull out oh yeah now
is that something that working for such
an indie film like that versus working
on like a large budget show versus doing
something animated is there a different
amount of patience and process and
writing those different formats uh yeah
you know I well with animation just
everything is I find like with the
comedy of it the jokes you write you got
to live with because they're coming back
they gotta be funny like in six months
so that's that that's the the one
difference with the animation process is
when you're writing it it has to be
funny on the page because you're not
going to be able to really improv too
much past a certain point it's also like
when you get in the the booth to record
a when you're shooting a show or a movie
you're able on the day to if a scenes
not working you could talk it over with
the other cast and improv stuff and and
try to take it in some different
directions and and try to find it if it
doesn't feel like it's working but with
animation like people have careers so
like you're off doing something else
while that person's in the booth and
they don't have the luxury of then
improving with the other actors so
you're you're sort of stuck with what
right and if you're like this scene
doesn't work you you realize when you
send it back you're sending it back to
like people have to draw and like it's a
lot of work to be like I don't like this
one too much
can't improv animation especially
imported and exploit animation yeah
now with this property in particular is
based off a comic and we're living in an
age of so many kind of adaptation that
people don't know our comics it's not
like spider-man
there's things that are like like lone
wolf and cub is Road to Perdition with
Tom Hanks and and there's the boys
coming out which is insane oh yeah is
this are you guys part of the comic
community do you like comic books
themselves you like to read the funny
pages yeah yeah totally I'm a I'm a big
comic book reader I think what we also
like about this project is like the
Freak brothers is a really funny comic
that not too many people know about I
mean I feel like more old-school crew
does but cool like we just we just met a
guy inside a cameraman he was in his
sixties he said and he saw some was like
oh yeah I was like I met Arnold
Schwarzenegger and I didn't care it's
cool and like I'm shooting the show for
HBO called the righteous gemstones
caucus 18 and I was reading the comic
cuz we were developing the show and John
Goodman stops me and he's like he's like
the Freak brothers and I'm like yeah man
I'm doing the cartoon I'm developing it
into a cartoon and he like freaked out
and he was like
that's so awesome so it's cool it's like
it's this cult thing with guys that are
like probably 60 years old and and then
now we're gonna make it so younger folks
can can also get on board
that's rather than this loyal following
that's about to have this resurgence
yeah we're we're speaking all the old
dos be cool for cartoons like you the
Venn diagram strong yeah yes oh my god
my dad is like geek you know yeah really
that's a good straight update so comic
book wise were at Comic Con yep what are
you guys reading what are you digging
sure what new yeah I'm trying to think
uh what was that I just read was called
skyward or something there's some weird
rounds a company that's that's uh I
should have had it I should have looked
at the cover before I came here and
brought it up I'm actually not the
biggest comic fan okay Blake is
definitely more so I'm mourned like
cartoons and stuff but I just saw a
spider verse just like that I was like
literally like three days ago yeah
because I hadn't had time to watch it
now it's fine like I want to watch blew
me away man it was incredible
there's a movie talk about existential
crisis for children and interdimensional
theory yes translatable yeah I'm on
board with this I'm in a reality check
I love when Marvel goes fully animated I
wish they made all their movies just
like completely animated because it just
comes out so perfect I thought that
movie kicked a serious butt and Lord
Miller's consistency is crazy yeah Mehta
modernism is taken over and it's really
incredible to serve fantastic I love
those guys yeah they knock it out the
park well I'm excited to see you're
taking a cartoon and especially if
there's loyal following I I'm really
excited as hear people talking about the
Freak for others and just gonna come out
of nowhere and I instantly recognizable
shirts like the iconographies there and
you guys are so zealous and invested
yeah so it sounds like the perfect match
bring the freaks out we want to meet
them dude free party
unrest Thompson's freak party bringing
it back it's all coming full circle of
it well I appreciate it guys when do we
get to see a piece of it next year up
next 2020 okay we're not exactly sure
man everything will be done but we're
still in that were like still deep in
the writing process right now but we
comic-con is obviously such a huge event
we wanted to get ahead of it and let
people know that that this is what we're
doing this morning up on the slate I'm
excited hopefully next year you guys can
come back if all goes well yeah that's a
night tomorrow night go we'll be on
stage sort of good behavior moderate
behavior for the cartoon well I
appreciate it guys stay tuned for more
stuff and stay tuned to 20/20 to check
out the show I can't wait all right
thank you